moments from now the White House
coronavirus task force will be coming
out for another briefing and we'll take
you there once it happens but first to
today's other big news Barack Obama
finally endorses Joe Biden for months
the former president sat on the
sidelines and stayed silent watching his
VP get pummeled in an absolutely brutal
primary season but now that Biden has
emerged victorious things have changed
in a major way honesty and humility
empathy and grace that kind of
leadership doesn't just belong in our
state capitals and mayor's offices it
belongs in the White House and that's
why I'm so proud to endorse Joe Biden
for President of the United States
choosing Joe to be my vice president was
one of the best decisions I ever made
and he became a close friend and I
believe Joe has all the qualities we
need in a president right now so why did
it take so long remember it's been
well-documented that Biden wasn't
Obama's first choice Obama reportedly
tried to get Biden not to run for
president the former president was
worried that his former VP would quote
embarrass himself meanwhile Joe Biden
desperately needs the support of Bernie
Sanders far-left supporters Sanders own
campaign spokeswoman openly attacked
Biden and refused to endorse so listen
to Obama's pitch to those disaffected
Bernie supporters if I were running
today I wouldn't run the same race or
have the same platform as I did in 2008
the world is different there's too much
unfinished business for us to just look
backwards we have to look to the future
Bernie understands that and Joe
understands that it's one of the reasons
that Joe already has what is the most
progressive platform of any major Party
nominee in history all right judge
Jeanine first of all the thing that
struck me was how gray the former
president has going on up top but I
guess that's what happened
so what did you think about the
endorsement I know you can't do it in
front of 30,000 crowd you know at a
swing state it's a it's a pitch on the
Internet what did you think well I think
it's disingenuous at best I think that a
lot of what he said doesn't really hold
any water
what does hold water is yeah he's
probably more progressive but most of
the progressives including the the the
Sanders people are gonna disagree
because they want Medicare for all they
want their student debt eliminated and
they want a wealth tax and Joe Biden
isn't in favor of any of that but you
know I can't help but think and maybe
you know it's just a skeptic in me I say
to myself who is Joe Biden why does
Obama want to get involved in this think
about it Jesse when was the last time
you remember a president an ex-president
actively campaigning against a sitting
president this is contrary to anything
that we've seen in this country before
but Barack Obama hates Donald Trump so
much that he's going to continue to go
after him and it doesn't matter to him
whether it's an empty suit like Joe
Biden or you know a guy who doesn't know
where he is or what he's thinking you
know maybe they've got people who around
and we're gonna control Joe and maybe
that's too Obama's benefit but make no
mistake the fact that we're just hearing
from Obama doesn't mean that he just
showed up he's been in the background
the whole time pulling strings yeah
you're definitely right about that and
I'm wondering to your point about former
presidents Dana getting out there four
years later and campaigning against
incumbents did Bill Clinton get out
there in 2004 and go after Bush I from
what I remember he laid pretty low yeah
I'm trying to remember and I don't I
don't think that he did and also I think
in 2012 I was just trying to think about
that as the judge was saying that I
don't believe that 43 did anything
beyond congressional and Senate races
during the 2012 race so yes I think that
probably holds true but I am you know i
I've been telling you from the beginning
Jesse when you everybody was goading
Obama why aren't you doing it I said he
will not do it until it is
secured that whoever the nominee is
going to be it will be and I think that
it's a little bit like a sugar high
because now that he's done it and we're
in the middle of a pandemic it's like I
don't think it's gonna have a lot of
long-term energy
he didn't include a fundraising link in
the video which I think probably the
bytom team really needs and usually I
would be quite dismissive of what former
campaign aides said about something but
the Bernie Sanders campaign people they
actually have quite a large social media
following and they're not buying it just
because Bernie cave they're not gonna
cave so there's a lot still to be
decided and who knows in a middle of a
pandemic how President Obama could be
effective I do think he's been effective
and I think when the history books are
written when Biden won in South Carolina
we'll find out that Barack Obama had a
little bit of something to help nudge
that endorsement in the right direction
from sent on from congressman Clyburn I
think you're probably right about that
one can you translate what Obama meant
when he was making the pitch to the
Bernie bros what did that really mean
what was he selling there well I think
he's saying in fact you have a more
progressive candidate in Joe Biden than
he was then Obama was when he ran in Oh
8 and 12 and even when he left office
there are a lot of people on the Left
who wanted the president to be even more
aggressive with regard to health care
coverage in this country things like how
do we pay for college but the larger
point is here again speaking to what
judge Jeanine mentioned you know
remember that Bill Clinton had had a
little problem there that wasn't exactly
helpful to Al Gore and President Bush
had the war which wasn't popular and
that wasn't going to be helpful to John
McCain that's a different context right
now you've got a candidate Joe Biden who
has defied all the doubters and all the
people who called him names and he's
beat all comers in the Democratic Party
and now he has the former president the
most popular Democrat in the country the
former president as I said riding
shotgun and you couldn't have someone
better because you
what Joe Biden knows Barack Obama Barack
Obama knows Joe Biden he can speak to
his character about you know the empathy
and kindness that we see in middle of
this pandemic from so many Americans now
going to the White House as he said but
also to the fact that gee this is a guy
that helped us with the recovery this is
a guy who helped us when it came to
dealing with Ebola this is the guy who
knows what he's doing he's knowledgeable
he's experienced he's ready for the job
and with regard to this business about
about Sanders and who's who I think it
was Sanders a PR person or press
secretary who said I'm not endorsing Joe
Biden I can't even tell you the woman's
name but again it's a unified Democratic
party at this point against Donald Trump
this is why Donald Trump was going to
the Ukrainians he didn't want to face
this well I would disagree about a
strong economic recovery under Barack
Obama and Joe Biden I'd also disagree
about a unified party Greg what do you
think about it all well I heard that you
know when Joe was told that he got
Obama's endorsement
he said well did he also write for
deposit-only don't you find it nobody
liked that joke I don't even think I
liked it I find it awesomely ironic I
find it awesomely ironic that Joe Biden
is running for president in the era of
social distancing I mean isn't that the
cruelest punishment you can put on him
that he can't touch anybody through this
entire period look you know no you know
what Obama Obama is like remember when
your teacher would march you over to
another student and goad you to
apologize or your parents forced you to
invite the kid you don't like to your
birthday party because his mother and
your mother play bridge that's Obama
endorsing Biden his heart's not into it
at all we know that but he felt he had
to do it so there and because Joe I
don't believe Joe was there for
everything Joe does not strike me as
somebody you go to to ask for
professional advice he's the guy at work
who's dressed really well as a nice
watch he's always
every holiday party when there's free
pizza but no one really knows what he
does and he's loves to wear the bomber
jacket and the AV in the aviator
sunglasses
he loves the expense account he loves
being that guy but he's not the guy that
really knows what was going on and he
never really wanted to and say one more
thing before we go to break Jesse the
thing that infuriates me is the
allegations bite bite what is it Tara
Reid is that her name the woman who
claimed that she was sexually assaulted
and the New York Times coming out and
saying we've got no other complaints
there's no pattern of sexual misconduct
the guys sniffing every woman he ever
met going up and down her back her hair
her neck and you know they're saying
this guy's the greatest thing since
sliced bread I mean Greg you're
absolutely right social distancing is
going to be the biggest punishment the
guy could ever have and I'm discussing
with the times and you know me too ought
to get their act together it applies to
the Democrats too
yeah but I'm running in the age of
social distancing is like Trump running
before social media it's not going to
work all right